vous répondez à toutes les questions il
y a pas de tabou il y a pas de pudeur
par exemple je tiens Ardisson essaie de
pas avoir de tabou hein enfin bah je
suis tiens des sons il y a quelques
années il vous demande qui commence
c'est lui Philippe quelle est la taille
de ton de ton sexe et vous répondez 18
cm
mais ça c'est parce que il y avait Rocco
Siffredi ouais moi je voulais pas le
vexer oui mais sauf que vous êtes là
[Applaudissements]
mais qui répond à ça
qui me sur déjà à l'époque tu vas chez
Ardisson
libre de parler du coup et n'importe
quoi alors vous continuez vous dites ma
femme est saoulée je suis addict au sexe
j'ai besoin de faire l'amour tous les
jours
pourquoi j'ai dit ça parce que c'est la
vérité
mais surtout pas pardon comment je peux
pas moi tous les jours ça va une fois
par jour ça va je peux pas en combien de
temps ça dure
longtemps
on continue mais je joue près c'est un
festival mais je vous aime tellement
tout à l'heure vous m'avez dit je peux
vous tutoyer bah ouais bien sûr voilà
moi j'aime bien les femmes avant
l'arrivée de la mienne j'étais à ça
liqueur
vous pensez que vous avez fait l'amour à
combien de femmes
j'ai pas je crois environ
parce que c'était à l'époque on disait
c'était valorisant ouais faire dans la
dans le nombre que dans la qualité c'est
les bronzés quoi au poids mais environ
en rigolait à l'époque une fourchette
[Musique]
ça va très vite non mais c'était
évidemment on rigole c'est pas c'est pas
autant évidemment on rigole et on sait
que vous êtes cash vous dites de très
jolies choses sur votre femme que vous
aimez vous dites quand on a une femme
aussi trois enfants exactement mais
c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui est
arrivé quelque chose de nouveau c'est
que l'ancien Candeloro il aurait fait
deux émissions et on l'aurait sorti le
mouvement me too qui est arrivé
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
c'est bien déjà qui est pas d'abus et
puis des gens avec leur pouvoir arrivent
à des fins sexuels en fait sur poser des
jobs comme j'ai un peu entendre ce que
vous n'avez jamais fait
alors après le problème c'est il faut
pas tout mélanger parce que aujourd'hui
c'est ce que disait la jeune fille dans
le couloir en attendant on confond
peut-être aujourd'hui un sentiment de
drague et de sexisme comme par exemple
qu'on a passé la quand vous dites tout
d'un coup et que Nelson il regarde ses
pieds vous dire regarde pas que les
pieds Nelson aujourd'hui avec Mewtwo ça
c'est déplacé ou pas on peut bah moi je
le prends pas comme déplacer sinon je le
sors pas mais quelqu'un a mal
intentionné peut effectivement appuyer
sur ce sur ce genre de propos et de me
faire passer pour un gros et un
gros sexiste non mais je pense que de la
part de Philippe en vérité il y a une
sorte de d'espièglerie chez vous voilà
donc ça passe ça dépend qui le fait et
comment c'est fait en fait c'est
toujours la même chose
la poitrine d'une femme est belle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le problème de Philippe à l'époque mais
qui était pas un problème c'était ça
spontanéité c'est-à-dire parce qu'il y
avait pas que c'est un avantage
c'est une patineuse asiatique qui avait
fait une superbe
elle aura bien mérité son bol de riz bon
c'était pas son bol de riz d'un bon bol
de riz je dis après une telle
performance parce que j'aurais pu dire
ça dans l'italien il a bien patiné il va
se taper une pizza quel est le mal dans
tout ça en fait c'est comme si nous on
nous rejoindre
après une telle performance ça va
pouvoir se taper un bon bol de riz mais
est-ce que est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ça par
exemple aujourd'hui très sincèrement
vous vous dites vous après coup
je suis foot colère qu'on tombe dessus
ou moi je reconnais c'était déplacé non
non je peux pas dire que c'était déplacé
parce que pour moi il y avait aucun mal
dans tout ça d'ailleurs
cette patineuse j'ai même pas pu lui
dire mais je m'excuse parce que s'il y a
pas de sentiment méchant c'est vrai à
mes propos si j'accepte des excuses ça
veut dire qu'il y avait un sentiment
avant de devenir consultant pour pour
France Télévisions vous aviez dit
j'aurais adoré je ne comprends pas le
cinéma m'a pas appelé parce que je suis
un showman mais moi ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est c'est perso pourquoi
après deux médailles et une telle
personnalité vous vous êtes perdu dans
des fermes célébrités des des trucs ou
ça une fois qu'on a fait la danse une
fois qu'on a fait la Ferme Célébrité on
peut plus on peut on peut plus les faire
du cinéma vous comprenez ce que je veux
dire est-ce que vous vous êtes pas perdu
un peu à l'époque il y en a qui ont fait
la ferme et puis derrière ça a lancé une
carrière moi je voulais pas lancer une
carrière en faisant la Ferme Célébrité
non je faisais pour deux choses déjà
j'ai bien tiré mon épingle du jeu parce
que j'étais allé comme invité donc j'ai
passé que 4-5 jours là-bas
tu étais à la ferme entre la ferme pour
me dire je vais peut-être trouver un
rôle au cinéma heureusement parce que
non j'aurais été vite déçu je l'ai fait
aussi pour l'argent faut pas se cacher
c'est une belle proposition financière
oui non mais à un moment donné moi je
fais un sportif une fourchette tout à
l'heure on va parler on va parler
peut-être de la retraite aujourd'hui si
j'ai pas fait toutes ces émissions si je
le fais pas pour l'argent aujourd'hui je
suis quoi je suis peut-être dans la rue
et c'était quand même à la fin de
célébrité j'ai pas le droit de rêver
dans tous tes bouquins il y a les
montants
c'était 100000 euros en tout cas
on me dit ça plus de 10 ans et après
prescription tu peux y aller moi c'est
peut-être 50000 euros la semaine pour
quatre jours
après tu enlèves les 33 un tiers
d'imposition sur les impôts vont en
parler c'est pas trop le truc
on a un contact commissaire aux comptes
sur le plateau mais j'ai découvert que
vous étiez un homme de enfin je le
savais vous êtes un homme de cœur est-ce
que je ne savais pas c'est que vous avez
sauvé la tête de Nelson Monfort puisque
à 70 ans c'est la règle on doit être
licencié de France Télévision c'est vrai
que je trouve débile mais c'est la règle
et vous avez dit moi c'est très simple
si Nelson fait pas les prochains jeux je
les ferai pas non plus et du coup ils
ont donné les jeux à Nelson ça c'est
rare ici c'est très rare ça
alors déjà il y a
il y a deux choses c'est que moi
j'estimais que Nelson a même s'il va il
fait ses 70 ans cette année les Jeux
Olympiques de Pékin c'était l'année
dernière ils étaient encore dans les
temps je disais que c'était dommage de
pas avoir Nelson pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 qui me concerne
pas du tout ce que je ne ferai rien à
Paris 2024 pour France Télévisions en
tous les cas pour le moment il y a rien
de prévu mais lui sa carrière les gens
ils l'adore il est au bord d'un stade
donc c'était ça me paraissait tellement
évident et puis après j'ai dit si je
fais pas si vous n'arrivez pas à trouver
une solution pour le reconduire pour
2026 à 1000 ans Cortina je me vois pas
moi repartir avec un nouveau journaliste
avec qui on va être aussi drôle aussi
marrant avec tout ce que et sur l'argent
il y a un truc qui est intéressant que
j'ai appris quand vous étiez patineur
pas professionnel on va dire amateur
vous gagnez pas d'argent du tout on
commence à gagner voilà maintenant oui
on commence à gagner quand on est
professionnel et du coup vous avez gagné
beaucoup d'argent il y a eu des choses
et tout ça puis après on vieillit c'est
compliqué de faire les choses de glace
comme on avait beaucoup fait mais vous
dites aujourd'hui moi il y a pareil vous
avez donné le montant donc je vous
laisse si c'est prescription vous dites
moi j'ai fait un calcul simple j'ai
besoin d'un montant précis pour vivre
par mois oui alors en fait moi je suis
en distribution de dividendes sur ma
société qui est URL qui a été montée en
1994 pour éviter que je sois déclaré
professionnel il faut quand même ce
salarié c'est la loi en fait c'était une
espèce de société tirelire on a pouvoir
pas parler compta mais c'est quoi le
montant qu'il vous faut pour vivre par
mois il fallait 150000 euros de factures
aujourd'hui plus à passer à 200000 parce
qu'il y a aussi des actifs il y a des
choses qui en gros vous en gros il vous
faut 10000 euros par mois pour bien
vivre à peu près
pour moi j'ai compris mais c'est
tellement parler en plus le chien c'est
tellement ce que les croquettes ça coûte
cher ah c'est vrai c'est très hâte d'en
parler et j'en ai pas j'aimerais
d'un autre sujet qui m'intéresse parce
que là aussi vous dites la Fédération de
patinage comme toutes les paquets par
exemple mais la Fédération de patinage
il y a eu un peu des magouilles et
parfois on se situe aussi il fait les
faire gagner des athlètes étrangers on
se souvient de Surya Bonali qui a refusé
sa médaille est-ce que c'était c'est
vrai que si on avait couché avec les
Juifs peut-être qu'on a envie les
meilleurs places voilà voilà
est-ce que voilà vous avez senti que
dans le patinage on le savait bien avant
c'était assez subjectif bon par contre
qu'on avait bien c'est que le juge
devait assumer sa note quel pays il
était comment il s'appelait où il
dormait à l'hôtel et on pouvait aller
lui tirer l'oreille si on était vraiment
pas contents
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui en fait bon vous
avez des juges qui sont là et qui
appuient sur des touches et qui on a
qu'un chiffre c'est très difficile de
savoir qui a voté mal ou qui a voté bien
pour un tel ou un tel on peut dire bien
longtemps après et vous dites un truc
très fort aussi et je le note
quand je vois Cyril vous dites ce qui
fait la différence entre un patineur
c'est pas que le talent c'est la force
mentale on a quatre ans pour se préparer
trois minutes pour voilà et la
différence pardon et je l'aime beaucoup
mais notre brin Joubert qui était
champion du monde et vous champion
olympique c'est que c'est
le montant olympique peu importe la
couleur c'est mieux quand on est
médaille d'or ça c'est clair c'est
mental c'est déjà bien c'est déjà très
très bien voilà faut pas s'occuper de la
couleur la médaille Joubert que j'adore
les champion du monde je pense que toute
sa vie leur a se regrette de pas avoir
une médaille olympique c'est vrai qu'il
y a beaucoup de sportifs qui
malheureusement ont été plusieurs fois
champion du monde et il ira toujours la
dernière marche ouais du podium pour
atteindre le podium olympique et c'est
vrai que c'est une frustration et vous
dites ça se passe dans la tête voilà
c'est comme dans beaucoup de sport
surtout que nous il y a une technique
très importante donc faut pas la rater
si on rate le premier saut par exemple
qui sont dans la première seconde c'est
mort et surtout sur le premier programme
qu'on voit moins souvent à la télé
on s'en fout complètement tout le monde
se regarde à vie donc en fait d'Artagnan
bien sûr l'utilité des choses incroyable
et alors vous dites ça c'est incroyable
là attention révélation donc là vraiment
c'est vous tous sur votre canapé vous
dites je ne comprends pas je veux
devenir ministre des Sports on m'appelle
pas
alors c'est pas une vraie orbite de
finir ministre des Sports parce que
souvent quand ils arrivent là-haut ils
disent rien ils font plus rien pour les
sports on est un peu
d'accord il y a un président ou une
présidente pas une corones parce qu'une
présidente avec des corones ça serait
peut-être mal venu mais voilà et
simplement ça serait une mission oui la
mission vous l'accepteriez un ministre
de sport ça serait au moins de mettre en
place un statut des sportifs de haut
niveau notamment pour ce qu'on discutera
peut-être plus tard sur les retraits sur
l'aspects
on n'est pas du tout reconnu on est
reconnu on est reconnu quand on fait une
médaille on vous tape sur l'épaule super
merci le président de fédé du moment etc
c'est super mais dans sa tête il s'est
bien tu me sauves ma mise en fait pour
les quatre prochaines années je pourrais
demander des subventions au ministère
mais toi après 10 ans plus tard
l'ordre national du Mérite et je me
souviens moi j'ai pas demandé mais c'est
génial d'avoir une récompense comme ça
et 15 jours plus tard j'ai reçu la
facture de la médaille et de l'avion
et comme j'avais déclaré que je passais
professionnel elle a dit bon maintenant
il est pro lui
c'est quelqu'un qui a bossé 4 ans qui
fait la fierté d'un pays les médailles
de bronze dans le monde entier on lui
donne médaille à 50000 balles pardon
mais pour 4 ans de travail c'est pas
lourd et il a même plus loin moi j'ai
dit à force de avec tout ce qui se passe
je me suis dit pourquoi au lieu de
recevoir 15000 € à l'époque on m'aurait
pas donné 20 ou 30 trimestres pour mes
pour ma retraite on va parler tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui je pourrais
peut-être prétendre à dire je prends en
retraite alors que là il faudrait avec
le guide social qu'on a fait pendant le
covid il faudrait que je patine jusqu'à
70 ans pour partir avec une sorte de
1300 1400 balles vous le faites encore
le supérieur avec les deux hanches en
plastique oui ça tient ça tient tout va
bien c'est quand même quelque chose mais
on va parler après
bien sûr alors il y a une petite frange
j'ai pas aimé
ah ça c'est la petite phrase que j'ai
pas aimé c'est la mouche dans le lait la
mouche dans le lait j'ai une expression
tomber j'ai toujours mes bras vous avez
dit j'ai gratté dans une dans une cité
avec une famille modeste et c'était très
dur de faire du partage vis-à-vis de mes
amis je ne voulais pas qu'on me prenne
pour un c'est quelque chose qui
m'aurait blessé
je peux comprendre que non non mais
[Applaudissements]
je peux comprendre que la mouche te pose
un problème
alors il faut repartir j'avais 8 ans on
est en 78 d'accord on est dans une
période où effectivement moi je vis j'ai
une sœur deux frères à la maison ça
parle plus hétéro machin et tout ça donc
on est éduqué dans cette façon de vivre
et quand à chaque fois qu'on disait que
je faisais du patinage on me traitait de
ou tarloz très bien en fait c'est
pas et c'est quand on le disait ça tu
dis bah non le patin sport viril c'est
super compliqué il va essayer de faire
un accès et puis après on en reparle
souvent
en fait ma question elle est si
aujourd'hui quelqu'un vous disait par
exemple tiens je crois que Philippe
qu'on est l'euro est gay ça vous
heurterait déjà ça m'inquiéterait parce
que je n'en serait pas aperçu
mais aujourd'hui en fait
comment on a la possibilité peut-être de
tout essayer sans avoir sans que
personne ait un avis sur ce que tu as
choisi de faire j'ai peut-être que si
j'avais si j'avais eu l'opportun de vos
enfants si on rapporte le truc 30 ans en
arrière d'aujourd'hui avec le mytho et
tout ça peut-être que je me serais
laissé tenter j'en sais rien non t'es
pas de vos enfants est gays aujourd'hui
ça vous posera non ça me pose pas aucun
problème
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes et je le dis et je le redis
pareil
vous voulez faire des petites choses
chirurgie
il y a que les cheveux maintenant qui
commence à me déranger parce que bon ça
c'est Jean-Michel
[Applaudissements]
parce que pour le coup Jean-Michel c'est
magnifique hein
je vous montre des images il y a 10 ans
moi je peux te raconter comment ça se
passe
franchement je vous le dis à propos de
beau gosse
petite question que j'ai piqué à mon ami
Jordan Deluxe que j'aime beaucoup qui
fait de très belles audiences je sais
pas quelle a pas son émission sur pas me
le dire ça me fait plaisir de lui faire
de la publicité ou le matin je sais pas
quelle heure
de luxe 9h 9h voilà à 9h de 9 à 10 et il
est très doué ce garçon selon vous quel
est l'animatrice du PAF la plus sexy bah
c'est toi
[Rires]
là ils sont drôles quand même le
marchand j'aime bien
ok ça roule physiquement en tous les cas
après plus sexy
ce qui est dommage ça va pas être le
physique en fait ah c'est dommage
d'accord donc belle mais pas sympa
inégale
ou qu'on comprend les mots c'est très
bien l'animateur que vous aimez le moins
il y en a pas parce qu'après il
m'invitera plus à son émission
est-ce que vous préférez franchement
pour vous le meilleur truc vous préférez
il y a pas il y a pas de meilleur c'est
chacun son style et puis voilà est-ce
que tu es ce que j'ai connu Foucault
tout le monde bien sûr Cyril toi je
trouve vous avez un style particulier et
voilà qui qui fonctionne donc c'est des
étapes voilà c'est par décennies souvent
l'animateur le plus beau le plus beau
sexuel
je trouve ce picos magnifique j'ai peur
de te gêner c'est toi oh merde
la semaine prochaine il est chroniqueurs
il y en a un qui a beaucoup de charme
c'est de Laos
de travail et si tu ne coupes la mèche
c'est mort elle est hyper travaillé il a
il a quoi il a 7 ans sur les cheveux il
a une petite tu sais il s'est fait un
petit blond
voilà le premier chiffre c'est la
couleur le deuxième c'est le reflet je
crois qu'il reste deux c'est bien bossé
c'est bien bossé non mais tu reviens là
je te mets des cheveux on te look un peu
avec son talent je te jure en
chroniqueur tu es un génie
on y va on essaye t'as vu ce qu'il m'a
dit on y va Marseille et en plus
tout à l'heure je lui ai dit qu'elle
était le salaire qui avait pas du tout
indigne et il m'a dit OK et pour que lui
dise ok c'est que j'ai démarré trop fort
ok ouais c'est ok vous restez avec nous
mais il faut rester qu'il reste brute au
contraire pardon
ça va être difficile à mon âge je pense
non parce que j'aime bien c'est que les
gens comme ça
ils sont toujours les gens les plus
fidèles c'est-à-dire que vous avez vous
êtes fidèle aux femmes vous avez la même
femme vous êtes fidèle à vous
convictions à vos amitiés sur votre
femme vous dites je la trompe pas mais
je matte elle sait que j'aime bien mater
je mate je mate je mate ah mais sinon tu
me crève les yeux tout de suite et puis
on en parle faut mater quoi comme si
vous avez on en avait marre je raconte
des conneries on coupait la langue ça
serait réglé c'est qui la plus sexy du
plateau là
non c'est moi
[Rires]
sur un terrain
par rapport aux âges je pense qu'il y en
a pas une plus sexy que l'autre
il va être il va être ministre alors
dernière question il est pas sur votre
dossier c'est quoi Magalie
et Nicolas debault ah je les
adore les deux le seul le seul truc
c'est que je viens de me rendre compte
c'est un métier c'est un dossier plus
compliqué que ça en a en fait
comme moi qui va déjà un peu connu donc
on va m'attendre un peu au tournant et
puis finalement nous on vient de nous
écrire aussi un comment une pièce pour
Nelson et moi et génial c'est peut-être
on va peut-être commencer par ça ouais
plutôt que le one man le one man ça peut
attendre c'est un très beau ce que vous
dites que c'est un métier parce que il y
a quelques temps j'ai dîné chez mon ami
Guillaume frisquet que j'adore et il y
avait un comédien qui était là fameux
comédien qui n'a jamais tourné dans rien
à 35 ans il a fait que je crois qu'il
avait une apparition de Plus belle la
vie mais il parlait beaucoup parce que
les comédiens et que de lui et à un
moment donné il me dit je me laisse
encore un ou deux ans et puis si
vraiment ça marche pas je ferai de la
télé
alors bien sûr et bien connu à la télé
c'est les raté voilà il me reconnaîtra
je lui fais un gros bisou